good morning gone so couple months ago
you're like I think the underlying
problem is that almost everything on the
Internet is dependent upon advertising
and advertisers in my opinion are
terrible at measuring the value in the
creator viewer relationship so hey
please fix this problem during my
paternity leave okay thanks and then you
had a baby seen here in this
professional artist's rendering and I
set off on my own to solve this
extraordinarily complicated problem and
not to brag but I think that I have done
it so without further ado I must
announce that John and I will be
stopping the floor but this channel and
instead be doing a series of nerdy
workout videos called super cardio
brothers okay despite the fact that this
is an amazing idea I did not actually
solve the problem problem we were
solving as someone on Twitter so
succinctly put it is that advertisers
value views not viewers they don't care
how much you care about the thing that
you're watching they only care that
you're watching this it turns out is not
a problem that I can solve but it might
be a problem that we can solve the
advertising system is so ingrained that
there isn't a technological solution but
there might be a cultural solution
cultural changes need activation energy
and they need catalysts nerdfighteria
has become kind of a pretty powerful
force so I feel like nerdfighteria could
be the activation energy and subbable
could be the catalyst subbable if you
haven't already heard of it as a system
that lets you subscribe to content and
when you do that you get to decide how
much you would like to pay for it it
could be zero dollars a month or it
could be $1 a month there $5 a month or
$100 a month or it could just be a
one-time amount of money we're pretty
flexible subscribers get videos and
other content in their feed and possibly
maybe some other exclusive content but
you don't have to pay for it every
dollar that you do spend gets banked in
the subbable system and you can trade
that in for perks for that project that
might be a signed poster or a mention in
an episode or a message to your loved
one in the description launching this
with just crash course crash course is
our educational show it is very
expensive to make the Google grant that
paid for it for the last two years is
ending in without this system and
without the support of the people who
like it we won't be able to keep doing
it because it's actually educational
content and nothing capable of getting
the bajillion views necessary to pay for
through advertising crash course will of
course still live on YouTube it will
still be free but our hope is but not
people who can pay for
we understand the haunts of people can
we'll choose to so that all people can
have access to it we're asking and this
is weird
for you to pay for content because you
want to not because you're forced to
this is a weird cultural shift we want
to continue educating the world for free
as effectively as possible and that
takes money we also want you to help us
create that cultural change a change
that I think will result in a lot more
content being created that's really
engaging that people really love and
isn't just distracting we wouldn't have
been able to do this without Peter Jaros
our developer or Andrew Willis our
designer they are both really fantastic
and also of course we wouldn't be able
to do without the support of
nerdfighteria
thanks guys John it's been wonderful to
share this channel with so many amazing
people over the last few weeks during
your paternity leave but I am somewhat
relieved and very excited to say that I
will see you on Tuesday
subbable it's a little hard to spell su
b ba ble dot-com go there help us fund
crash course and defy capitalism